first of all let's talk about your hair
bruh are you were you mad at the wig
was that mad let's talk about it he was
mad
bro it looked like he tried to start her
only fans that day i didn't know what he
was going on
brian know what she was like that's how
you watch fights
i said i look like every wrestler that
lost wrestlemania
then had the nerves to make it as a
flyer triple game
[Laughter]
let's go for the pedigree look it really
looks like it's on you like your hair
look at that fake smiley giving us your
little teeth but the bottom just gonna
stay covered
how ridiculous looking is that bro it's
ridiculous i wish you hadn't really
i look like i should the grill have been
too much for these people
no what theo say my own little phone
a little pony bruh
bruh dude who's that is that yours no
it's my girls
yours i thought that was brandy from the
housewives of beverly hills
oh my my girl was rocking it and then
she's like it's just gonna look natural
take a picture and then she took it off
his lane there
and she goes you should try it on i put
on i was laughing
dude it is hilarious but did you see he
made a flyer with it
that's what pissed me off now let's talk
about it like i don't know what what are
we promoting here on tour i don't know
this is just fun okay okay well let's
have you come to the show it's fine
it gets a little weird a little bit i'm
loose yeah
i get it you lose yeah we got a guy i
look like vince neil i put vince meal
but what's funny is vince neal is
straight up vince meal now
have you seen it really dude are you
serious he don't know we need to get him
a bike
we put him in a group chat vince neil is
do you know who he is first team all
thick
he's the lead singer of uh molly crew
the guy you put in the group chat
yeah yeah that guy okay okay uh he looks
out
he's not gonna post a picture of him not
looking good chin
uh wait dude on google he's so
thick is he really yeah he looks like he
ate all the guitars damn just straight
up his name or just
just straight up his name nope straight
straight up his name and then if you go
to
images it's he's unrecognizable like go
oh
i can't talk too much [ __ ] i'm trying to
lose my weight right now but when i get
off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son